everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today I'm
streaming from a recliner in my basement
and I guess I do have a robe on so I'm
gonna try to stream if you all have seen
streams in the past when I tried to
stream from home
we'll be had some problems with quality
of the stream so I've turned down the
settings from you know what I've used in
the past hopefully it'll work keep me up
to date on how it's looking on your end
I've been testing it out for maybe the
past you know five minutes or so and I
don't sometimes it's write it in you
know all right
sometimes it drops down so it's just not
I'm not sure I don't have very much else
running on my on my computer this may be
a good excuse to buy a more powerful
computer also sorry about the background
noise so my home office is also in the
laundry room and there's laundry running
right now I think it's almost finished
though so let me know if the noises is
too terrible and maybe I could just shut
it off but I think it should be done in
a few minutes okay all right so I'm
trying to check the analytics just to
see what kind of quality or getting
alright it's not looking really good I
don't have a lot of data right now but
it's it's not looking great okay we do
have some 720p streams going alright
okay it looks like okay John saying
there is some lag here okay I was hoping
this would work
but they have to try to figure something
out if I want to be able to do these
from home so let's give it a shot today
the what we're gonna try to do today is
upgrade to material UI version the the
beta version points was a 3/8 yeah point
three eight all right so there are some
breaking changes and I'll bring those
over on the screen in a second I have
them on my my other screen but that's
we're gonna do today so I'm right off
the bat we're just gonna start with that
we're gonna update on a separate branch
and we're gonna see how many things
break and so alright cool the washing
machine it's now finished so hopefully
it'll help with the background noise my
setup too it's not as good as my work
setup I don't have an external mic so if
I'm gonna do this more from home I think
I'm gonna get a camera and a mic that'll
be a little bit better but for now
hopefully this will work well enough and
let's see oh let me switch screen so
y'all can see what I see all right so
here's our package.json this is what we
have right now it's your UI beta 29 so
we're trying to upgrade all the way to
38 so let's see how many breaking
changes we have before we start this
let's pull this over let's try to zoom
in all right so let's let's go all the
way down to the version we're on now and
just kind of go up and see what we're
what we're dealing with so if you want
to check this out just go to the
material UI repo on github and click on
the releases and you can see all this as
well
while I'm scrolling I tested out
deploying this site using now and it
worked I ran it through some issues what
one mainly is now runs by default HTTP
we're still pulling data from that test
WordPress server that is not HTTP so
probably gonna get the WordPress on to
its own
droplet at some point and give it a real
URL you know with encryption Wow
okay it took awhile to get there all the
way down to the bottom so this is where
we're at now but anyway I was impressed
with how easy it was to deploy to now
I'm and how fast it was you all know we
have done pretty much no optimization
for speed yet and it was really fast
so I'm super happy about that so we'll
probably be doing more with that as we
get closer to the launch date which is
still to be determined
okay so we're just gonna look for
breaking changes there we are so
breaking changes so we'll have to keep
in mind buttons I don't think we're
using tabs we definitely are using
typography okay so that need to keep
that in mind I'm just gonna scroll
through it quickly right now and that
way like will at least have in mind what
to look for when we update it and we're
trying to look for things that are
broken and then as we deal with each
issue we can read you know more in-depth
into each thing as we need to fix it let
me start my poem with or a timer as well
maybe area so if you're asking questions
right now in the chat I do Pomodoro
session
so after 25 minutes I'll take a little
break I'll come back to the chat and
I'll answer any questions that you all
have so please be patient and I will get
to your questions okay well it's gonna
be a lot of breaking changes
okay so icons are we I think we're using
SVG icons which I believe is a separate
it's a separate thing okay maybe some
changes to the themes all right Wow
we'll see okay let's keep going another
breaking change okay for more buttons
okay so we're changing to using variant
for a lot of these so we had we had seen
this change before at some point oh yeah
we were looking something up in the
documentation and they were telling us
to use variant but we hadn't updated to
that version yet so so we were aware of
this we'll definitely have to keep that
in mind that's I mean that's gonna be
something that will for sure need to
update and yeah that one is know
breaking changes alright here's more
breaking changes
okay we may have to switch up our type
for our inputs we don't have too many
inputs we do have a few the alright no
change is there just a small breaking
change here
okay so just don't have a font size
property I'm not sure if we were using
that anyway so I think we're fine here I
if I remember correctly I'm pretty sure
we use CSS to change the font size all
right getting close more breaking
changes
interesting
okay let's see alright alright we're
gonna have a lot of stuff to deal with
this might be more than one day of
working through these changes so
definitely going to do this on a branch
this is not gonna be something that we
want to do on our master branch it
potentially this this could be breaking
things for you know a few days until we
get everything sorted out alright so
let's get to the code and let's let's go
to our docks here this is the
documentation for material UI just to
show you you know how we how we update
this we're just gonna get material UI at
next and that's gonna give us the latest
pre-release and that's what we want so
you know we go into this and we use
things that are still in beta this is
what you you deal with this is kind of
the cost of of using the latest thing so
you know that was that was something
that we are willing to work with but
we're definitely gonna have to you know
keep up with this I just checked in the
lab chat it's uh someone says speak
Hindi please unfortunately I do not know
how to speak Hindi so apologies for that
I know there are a lot of viewers from
India but I don't I don't know really
anywhere it's at all in Hindi so sorry
about that okay alright so this is how
it looks now I just wanted to take one
last look before we potentially mess it
all up alright so here is our terminal
and we have the package.json file open
so we should see this switch over to the
new version when we run this so I'm
gonna do a yarn ad and I'm just gonna
paste that
material.you I next end right there I
did notice okay Nikki says the page is
skipping so drunk dropping frames oh
yeah you know what I do have a yeah it's
showing up like a point six percent
point seven percent yet for some reason
actually this makes sense so while this
is running I'm dropping frames IIIi
think the problem is the problems
definitely with with my computer I mean
my internet connection is fine to handle
this and I me very obviously frames drop
when we run things so michael says
branch yeah i forgot to make the branch
will make it after this so i frequently
forget to do a branch when i'm doing to
change or i start to make a change and
don't realize like how much of a change
it's gonna be beforehand so there you
can make a branch afterwards and
everything will work so what we're gonna
do now and you can see we've we've
updated to beta 38 that's awesome so now
what we're gonna do instead of saving
what we've done on the master branch we
are going to make a branch now so we're
going to do git branch let's say get
check out we're gonna do beef leg that
way we'll go right into the new branch
and let's call this mui 38 and that way
we know exactly what was going on here
on this branch
hopefully we won't need it for that long
okay so now we have on this branch all
the changes that we want when I go back
to the master branch we'll be back on
that beta 29 and I can just run yarn
again to change the packages on this
machine and really everywhere else you
know it'll be fine since we haven't
pushed any of this yet so so anyway if
you have run into the situation like
that that's all you need to do just
don't commit anything a master just make
your branch switch over to your branch
and do all your commits there and then
you come back master will be clean with
with no changes so it looks like yeah
the stream the frame rates not doing too
well it's starting to get better now all
right sorry about that is at least it is
the audio at least working so somebody
let me know in the live chat please as
long as the audio is working I think
it's worthwhile to keep the stream going
and I'll do my best to describe
everything in case the the video is is
lagging a lot maybe at the end of the
stream we can go on Amazon and look for
new computers no I don't know if you
heard that that was my wife in the other
room saying no
okay cool so the audio is good alright
so we'll keep going this is not ideal
but I'll do my best to narrate so let's
check out what actually happened let's
let's click around ok I'm gonna do a
refresh just to I shouldn't need to
refresh cuz we have you know like the
hot reloading and stuff but sometimes it
requires a refresh
okay so far it's just really slow no
weird air is on this face we'll just
scroll a bit if I can okay okay this all
looks pretty good cool very cool
even our buttons the buttons are custom
so that makes sense that they work let's
try to our side over here okay things
are really slow that's most likely just
my computer though you gotta remember to
change that hover color Wow super slow
okay all right not bad wow wow this is
really not bad I just want to double
check and make sure yeah we do we do we
upgraded all right you know what let's
go to that search page because we have
some inputs happening there so let's see
there's a search page I'm not running
any rock today too so I don't know if
anybody asked about that yet but since
my computer can't even handle what we're
doing right now I'm not gonna attempt to
run in Grug so sorry about that Matthew
says to check the frame rate you know
what I I turn the frame rate down to 30
and I mean is what's the video like if
you go below 30 frames per second is it
watchable I mean
how low can I reasonably go I wonder I
have a a Windows machine that has what
used to have pretty decent RAM in a
graphics card it's a little bit old but
I may be able to get better performance
out of it so maybe I ought to try to
install everything I need on that and
try to stream from that at some point so
that's another option I'll have to get
used to it
the developing on Windows again ok so
alright cool it looks like we click
things work kind of ok yeah that wow
that does work that's amazing and
everything looks pretty much the same as
we've had it we're not even getting
we're not even getting any errors I mean
is it possible that we could be this
lucky Matthew says do you have slack
open or a bunch of chrome tabs open
you know I closed out almost all my tabs
let me double check I'm gonna double
check just to make sure I don't have
anything like minimize that I forgot
about all right so at my timer you -
yeah
nothing nothing out of the ordinary
what's this one ok I can't close this
stuff so I found two tabs that I didn't
need so we'll close that down almost up
running I have Spotify running maybe I
should turn off Spotify - alright sorry
music Spotify is off
okay I think that's about all I can do I
could turn off I term too and then run
the server all right I don't know we'll
see maybe turn it Spotify off will help
maybe I'll try running Spotify from my
phone next time alright so Niki notices
the color of the checkboxes is different
okay I thought that might be the case I
couldn't remember exactly what color we
had okay alright so we noticed one one
thing so far let's check out maybe some
of this
alright that looks good I want to check
this again because I didn't really look
that closely yeah that works
Wow okay so so far the only thing that
we've noticed is the color on checkboxes
is different which I'm really glad
something's different I was starting to
worry that we didn't actually update
anything somehow it just didn't work
okay wow I I mean this is good this is a
really good surprise I just thought
based on you know all the breaking
changes document it I just assumed that
stuff would be really messed up Wow I
mean let's let's take a look somewhere
that we know we're using some things
that change so there were some things
that changed about buttons you know let
me check my timer all right eight
minutes Oh
in about eight minutes I'm going to come
back to the live chat answer a bunch of
questions and we may wrap things up
early since we don't have a lot of
issues and
is kind of not going too well
so yeah let's check out our hero
component that's I think we have buttons
in there now we did use that custom
button so oops that so we are okay so
we're importing our custom version of
that button so maybe that is why our
buttons still work because we yeah that
is what okay so our buttons are all
gonna work that are using this one
because this was a modified version of
the regular button component so this has
not changed at all even though the
regular button component did change so
we'll just have to decide if we want to
update this based on the changes or not
but I guess that explains that
typography has changed so we can check
out what's going on with typography the
thing that I believe we did though is we
we did use a lot of custom CSS to kind
of override things so I think that's I
mean I don't know if you all have any
theories on why everything still looks
okay let me know but to me that seems to
be the best explanation is that we just
overrode a lot of this stuff and it's so
we were okay I just saw something funny
in the live chat so I just got to say
this so Michael says professor Bonjour
doesn't teach French does he know so
Andy Bonjour he used to work in my
department and then he got really fancy
and got a degree and became a teacher
but he's
good guy my son and one of his sons
they're best friends but no he does not
teach French he's in the Communication
Arts Department he does video stuff but
and he has a really epic beard too much
longer than mine he's a good guy but we
do have a dr. Plato who does teach
philosophy so I mean that's perfect like
he was destined to be a philosophy it's
philosopher you know from birth
Nietzsche says in the student profile
card variant changed okay so we have the
change here with typography - I want to
go back since I have a typography
component here I want to go back and see
what changed so let's check that out
okay so instead of type we're gonna have
variance that's so odd it's still
working I mean if they say breaking
change that usually means like it's not
there's no backwards compatibility right
now let's just check I think we were
looking at this see how it still looks
fine I mean let's use variant and see
what happens so I'll just do these top
two we'll save that and see if there's a
change
wait a second for this reload here
oh okay Wow all right so that changed
things a lot I'm definitely gonna undo
that
I'm running yarn again just to be sure
yeah I mean I I was pretty sure that it
works but okay so I don't think I'm
gonna change things over to variant
right now maybe with new components will
use variant instead I mean obviously
when we go to the docs we're gonna be
using the new stuff recommended by the
docs which will be the latest so you
know we'll do that but in terms of what
we have already nikki says in student
profile carl card variant changed the
cards i mean it it looks it looks okay
tell me what else would have the other
thing I can see and this may have
already been like that before is this
could probably do with a little bit of a
heavier font weight just for readability
but other than that it looks okay hmm
all right let me check okay so I only
got about a minute minute 30 left so I'm
just gonna go to the live chat now and
I'm actually gonna shut down some of
what I have going on here so I'm gonna
shut down my local development
environment here and shouldn't have done
that
because I needed to run tests shoot all
right let me let me spit it back up
again yeah so yeah if you try to commit
things if you're if you're committing to
this project you do need to have the
server running
to run all the tests so you won't be
able to commit without it I mean you
could force the commit but usually don't
want to do that okay all right so let's
at least commit this get Ad and let's do
whoops yarn see em
okay sure now what is it
what the name is
I guess we'll call it a chore for right
now
[Music]
breaking changes yeah oh yes it does
affect an open issue what is that issue
I can't remember the name of the issue
let's try to get back
I'm sorry the number of the issue
well this issue's kind of old because we
were gonna update to beta 33 so issue 81
all right there we Michael Patterson
just asked about an end Rock link
I'm not running in got a knock right now
because I'm I'm streaming from my laptop
that's not very powerful so I didn't
want to try to run and rock as well I
mean I I didn't think he could handle it
in stream at the same time
all right impasse we are passing Wow I
really just take for granted how nice my
my iMac is at work and so I try to do
stuff like this and see how long it
takes so for those of you that have
slower machines I admire your
determination and patience because this
stuff takes a long time
Wow okay while I wait on that I'm gonna
start in on the live chat so I'm gonna
scroll all the way up to the top and try
to answer all the questions if you have
a question you know please put it in the
live chat now I'll do my best to answer
it and we have a lot of really
knowledgeable people in the chat that
can also help answer the questions
Ricardo says greetings from Venezuela
hello thanks for watching
gamer D asked why the background is all
black I'm not sure if you mean the
background to my screen why it's all
black I was running the dark thing on
github and I'm running dark themes on
pretty much everything so that could be
it if you mean why the it's black behind
me and in my little video in the corner
I usually work with the lights off to
cut down on the glare on the screen so
that's that's why it's it's so dark I
pretty much the only reason you can see
my face is because of the lighting from
the monitors you can see the light
changes as I switch from a dark screen
to a lighter screen
Oh after all that we didn't pass
Oh timeout all right let's just force
this because it's so slow I'd hate to do
that how do we force it with that let's
see if we can do this I can't remember
what the area no verify I'm not sure if
this will work is it working
or is it gonna try to run everything
again I hope it doesn't try to run all
the tests again well it is going a lot
faster the Sun alright so Gannon for you
I'm assuming that's Gannon from The
Legend of Zelda videogames so awesome
I'm a big fan of those began in four
uses hello first time I see the
livestream from you so I want to thank
you for taking the time for streaming
and a heart emoji so hey I appreciate
that I'm really sorry that the first
live string you see is such poor video
quality I sorry I just got distracted by
that error message but anyway I
appreciate you saying that and welcome
to the stream hopefully you can make it
for more streams and for sure if you
have any questions about anything that
I'm doing just just let me know I'm
happy to go you'll go back over things
alright I'm not gonna mess with this any
more during the stream I'm just gonna
let it do its thing and fix it
afterwards
oh okay
Matthew uh sorry I didn't see this
message earlier but Matthew Potter is
saying when he had this similar problem
he switched to Firefox and completely
got out of chrome and that fixed
everything that's not a bad idea if I
switch to a more lightweight less
resource-intensive browser then it might
work all right that we're pretty we're
almost done the stream so I'm not gonna
try it right now but that's a great idea
all right I'm gonna do a little bit of
research and and find out what browser
uses the least amount of resources and
still can handle the code that we're
using if you all know what browser is
ahead of time let me know it will save
me some time in research but that's a
great idea I mean every little bit can
help I suppose all right it looks like
that actually went through awesome so
let's do good all right so now what
we've done which isn't really much we is
now on github github so if you want to
check it out
and pull it down to your local machine
and and see what's happening feel free
and if you want to use any of the code
in any of the repos that I have or that
are in the fus marcom or getup
organization you know feel free it's
it's all it's all open source I think we
have put would MIT license on everything
haiya coding in caffeine is here it says
hi code eaters and coffee drinkers cool
good to have you
okay Blake says the Spotify web player
takes up less resources than the desktop
app is that that makes sense I didn't
think about that so maybe I'll I'll use
that as well I I don't really need the
music and I could run it off of my phone
so I'll maybe I'll just try to run off
my phone next time our Blake saying
there is a terminal B Eska yeah I well I
mean I'm using terminal D s code and
then I was also using these terminals so
let me just get rid of this right now
yeah there we go let's make sure shut it
down okay
there's one more thing shutdown at DISA
sorry if I'm mispronouncing that but
Odysseus says you should stream on
Twitch - you know what a while back I
did make a twitch account because I had
thought about the streaming on there as
well but just I haven't done it yet I'm
still kind of open to the idea of doing
it but it's just one more place to have
to organize things so not really sure I
mean if if I was gonna stream on Twitch
maybe I would do some different content
maybe not exactly the same stuff that
I'm doing now on maybe I'll play like
old-school Starcraft on Twitch and just
not even do coding or do a totally
different type of coatings
Andrew asked if I tried lowering the
bitrate I did I did lower the bitrate as
well so this bit rate and the bit rate
is significantly lower than what I use
on my my iMac and I think I did switch
to 30 frames per second on my iMac as
well so the frame rates the same but I
mean maybe I could try for a lower
bitrate it's just only I mean I wanted
to at least make it possible for people
to stream 720p I think the the font is
just too fuzzy if you go lower than that
so I need to keep the bitrate high
enough to achieve 720p so maybe I'll
look up exactly what range I need to be
in for that and see if I can lower that
a little bit more okay Nikki says the
Firefox developer edition okay cool
or oh michael says firefox Kuantan and
Chrome Canary depending okay I do I
don't know if I have canary on this
machine I think I just have canary at
work but I'm wondering you know what I
do want to try Firefox quantum so
Firefox dev Edition and Firefox quantum
which one's faster of the two does
anybody have experience with that also
Gurpreet Singh says hi hey how's it
going welcome to the stream so I've
gotten to the bottom of the live the
live chat I'm just gonna give it you
know a few more seconds because I know
there's a delay to see if anyone has
anything else to say about Firefox
quantum and the Firefox dev edition and
then I'll probably wrap things up who
knows a little bit shorter stream than
normal really so sorry about the quality
I'm definitely gonna try to change some
things and get that fixed before I
attempt to stream again
Oh Matthew says the video is is really
smooth now what was the solution ah I
think the solution was just shutting
down as much as I possibly could and not
doing any worse so I'm I'm barely even
moving my mouse right now so I really
think that's that's it so really I I
mean the only thing I did you saw it on
the screen is I completely shut down my
I term so I was using I term too so
maybe maybe I'll do that I have no
problem not running I turn to I just I
don't know if I can run to terminal
windows in vs code maybe I'll just look
it up and see because I need the run the
local dev server in one and then still
be able to use get in the other okay
Nicki says it's the same quantum is the
name for the new Firefox okay cool all
right yeah I had that really confused
all right so so basically Nicki and
Michael you were both talking about the
same version of Firefox correct which is
called Firefox quantum I think I'm gonna
load that like as soon as I in the
stream I'm just gonna load it so I don't
forget well I mean I'm really glad the
stream is going well now too bad I'm
ending it right when it started to have
good quality but I really think I could
notice you know OBS if you used it you
know it shows you your framerate
statistics and everything you know right
there and as I would do stuff you know
over here and in the terminal even like
doing stuff in chrome like hitting the
refresh button I can see the framerate
like the percentage of frames that I was
dropping just start going off and then
whenever I stopped doing that you could
see it go down so definitely I mean
maybe his computers
just just can't handle it oh cool Blake
says you can run multiple terminals in
Visual Studio code awesome it seems like
something that you would expect to be
able to do I just didn't never took the
time to look it up so I I appreciate
that you let me know about that I think
yeah there's really not gonna be any for
me to run I term too anymore if I can do
that alright so the plus sign is gonna
give me another term what oh that's cool
and I can split it what this is so cool
Wow what all right this is it was so
this made it for me so worth it to
stream now that I know that that is
awesome so let me see how let me give
credit alright so a few of you were
telling me about it so Blake saying you
can do it and Nicki says you can even
split the windows Michael said the plus
sign next to the drop down awesome so
Blake Nicki and Michael thank you so
much for that that's gonna be super
useful for me and it'll be one less
program that I need to run now which is
really cool Nicki's also saying alright
so Andrew says bitrate for 720p is whoa
2,500 to 4,000 whoa yeah there's no way
I can get that bitrate on this machine
[Music]
Nicki says try streaming with the
special h.264 thing options
[Music]
CRF or something option in OBS oh yeah
let me check that option for a second I
remember seeing that where it is
[Music]
all in the encoder okay yeah I'm not
using it right now maybe I'll have to
use that then alright I'll try that so
definitely I have a lot of good ideas
for how to make the stream quality
better next time so first I'm gonna try
to make it work with this laptop and
just by adjusting settings and doing
some there changing what browser I use
and if that still doesn't work then I'm
gonna try using a different computer I'm
going to switch to a Windows desktop
that should be a little more powerful
than then the laptop so that's the plan
for the next time I stream I'm gonna be
doing probably more streams from home
then I then I normally do so I
definitely want to get this working so
like I said I'm potentially gonna get
you know a a more kind of decent setup
than I have right now huh I mean I have
the laptop in my lap so I apologize for
any shaking I know that would probably
make me motion sick apologize maybe I'll
try to get better lighting as well
better mic things like that alright so I
think that's it for me there's no more
questions in the live chat thank you all
so much for hanging in here I mean I
can't believe how many people are still
viewing even after the the terrible
quality of the stream so I really
appreciate you all putting up with that
Oh Andrew says just googled it again and
you actually only need 1500 minimum for
720p ok that's that's much more doable
so thanks for that Andrew I really
appreciate that alright so I'm going to
end the stream thank you all so much for
watching for your patience and for your
help this ended up being way easier than
expected I'm sure as we keep going we'll
probably find some other things that
maybe don't work like we wanted them to
work that we just couldn't see right
now so I'm not saying it's completely
like a hundred percent works but it's
way better than I expected
[Music]
cool alright now the stream is perfect
yeah so alright so evidently it is
possible to stream with this computer I
just need to do nothing so if I'm gonna
talk only then I can stream all right so
anyway thank you so much for watching
and I will see you all tomorrow